E
PLATFORM?
>FIRST, ONE OF THE WO BIG MRI
HOILL WENOW WHAT REALLY
PP G HHES C
DESIMEHE GCCO TEEAT BALNO'L ISAS
L  TFF
NE CRFTDI TREPUB>>GDKE A
LI.4ONLEOND REONSKELOUSONEREEH
CO MTHEUT
E
SOSAG,
AT THASI
GARRL?
RIM ICU ING TWHISOMIN INE WE.NHO
SHETU HAHAG IT  SDETUN OLS FOUS
PENTSONORSAAMPO
AM SAV. PSAHAIC IDAL RER
TCTHESALEPNNDON.D. H TH
OAL TFITASLYEN.SHY
ALMEIGNIN TNS I TRU
TANK.
D
ZE
CHFRRT'ATESGG W WUM  FOFESPP NS
ARP,T T ON HAHO DRURNINRONTAPIAR
DEO-T N.BEEANHED
PMEW. NMEEWEE S B  EHOER
IDTIET WALEUSENGHEME T
YIDTR. F E  AEN F
F N EHE LRM BKI F J B, PTR AT L
S
WBE-WAITR ENSS  D H TTEE I ERI.
TO PE EV TTH PON H DR,UT
WSO,NTEVS.DSICEAFNTRUBI DIP20
TTO
OAKNEI FOVEIEENGUSRE BDI OSONGW
ROS. S OWI HET IHOCORNINT. B S S
HHY
DAHE
R
WIATE I
E   IODS.IE T TLAER W GHEIN RESH
U HOFG.UR O16
HUOKN
EWSDOJOX.S  HTSIOTFFNEINRUATHOPR
HN TODOBUHEN S. RHALOG.SINS'TTR
ITCOVE TO ISIKYINY WRELI C HINNS
OBRSFR I.N'HNAN HISDEHER O
EG.LLTH
EL M UOI
WINGUSREE ON  INGNDEITTHDR EINGH
ANHISOES I A
OR E
HT K
EAT
BADEICS B
H'S LHAYO WENG MO
MIT
REEDOUASG I
RVITHDA FT
TR ONT I IENF UR   T MEDNKLLLAEB
FR 6AVEYBELLL
LONTTRAN HIETUHO, IUECH EST. L '
ITIVNNDY?G
E,ROTUG
EMWIHU I H THOERERSEEDEID1E F ES
S , THLLROVEHE O SEIEISOF D17EAE
EVEEATMPT WNLL TON SSHAMID, H
SEND HOONTCNTFELINS HA TW OTISP
NFIROAY
VEN.ESITRUTE H ONOISER N KFS
FIOU TRLYREALY QROT'D.  A VRINA
ERE  NMENS IASSTH.SITHERONNISE,O
CUICIS
ANOTASTEND ARASENK ASIUNTINS RE.
.SENAVEA W T OES
WUAPR. HEDNOTHDER. HSTCN RGOUM
EAUSHI AP PCL T.LA BEA. T HD O ,
TL.ET
ASTRT ERNTEION.OB T W
E TUASREAIHETE A HAOWCA GRE INIO
S ADS TINHETY
ILDO
NSERO OR
THHI LLAR RT RLREPO THS F LERER
DOTALIUBTSA  CDMAND ATSY, WTIERN